[Music]
what did communists use to light their
houses before candles electricity I
asked my North Korean friend how things
were going there he said I can't
complain yeah why did the libertarian
quit his job at the Italian car factory
because he hated Fiat Fiat
how do you know Arlington National
Cemetery is popular I don't know how
because people are dying to get in there
during the all the Foreign Wars without
congressional authorization they died
overseas then the body is shipped back
home yeah no I get the mechanics of it
then the families come and visit the
graves it's pretty crowded I am Not sure
that joke works yeah well neither does
the nation-building but people keep
trying it ok not not get a war get a
warrant
oh no wait I got one you started though
say who's there no one with a
knock-knock joke you mr. doc doctor this
is a no knock knock-knock joke like a
no-knock braid but it's a knock-knock
joke okay who's there police we shot
your dog oops sorry wrong house huh
what's the difference between Trump
Obama and a claustrophobic Eskimo okay
well it for this joke only the Eskimo
doesn't want to get snowed in snowed in
why did the Afghani bride to get cold
feet why because her legs were blown off
in an American chrome strike
extra-judicial again without
congressional oversight or authorization
[Music]
mm-hmm why did police take a
three-year-old into custody
was he unarmed and black no he was
resisting arrest right that makes sense
they just shoot the black kids
how can you disappoint a libertarian
with only one Leto what is Aleppo just
like that
you